for the last six months I've been
visioning climate Futures with about 50
designers at Innovation consultancy Ideo
because I believe featuring will be a
powerful tool in our Collective climate
action
so come with me to 2034 let's check it
out
last night I went down and I watched the
offshore wind turbines in the bay you
know the ones they made into sculptures
so folks would let them be built by the
hundreds and looking up I could see all
the satellites between the Stars
analyzing their methane leaks and
biomatter lost really beautiful
I freelance and auditing greenhouse
gases so I'll get a ping to check out a
site where there might be a leak or
where reforestation might be working and
then I'll take a bunch of photos and
they use it for emissions accounting and
training the spatial image analysis
my last gig was verifying the algae
bloom happening off the coast of Chile
and since the government had offered a
cleanup bounty to protect their
biodiversity credits there was A Rush of
folks there to harvest and salsa the
bioplastics market
and with the algae bloom feeding the
global bioplastics market there's been
so much more algae-based product in
shops right now I just got my Ikea my
silly and stolen lamp too and I've been
redecorating my apartment in the
regenerative style which is a lot easier
because of the tax credits that we all
have but you know
that means consumption and we're all
trying to reduce while we land this
transition from fossil fuel production
within our individual carbon rations and
I still sometimes buy stuff you know
it's hard to change
but
things have also gotten more expensive
with the Global Tax from the ministry of
regeneration that goes to pay out
reparations to climate impacted
countries
I've been trying to stay away from stuff
with a carbon rating of less than three
but often not the good stuff and I did
get some fines this week so I joined one
of these consumer anonymous groups it's
been helpful to just kind of talk to
people who are also struggling in the
shifts to consume less and to shift from
single youth to reusable
fortunately that's been a little bit
easier lately and that's largely because
of the universal reusable packaging
system that we're all now required to
use and I love how I can pick up takeout
now in an airport in Tokyo and return
that container in any store in the world
including here in San Francisco my home
is getting a little full of these
standardized packages but I actually
love that the the universal reusable
packaging mandate killed custom
container shapes and labeling that now
all the brand is sort of expressed
stitchably and it feels like I'm
actually learning a lot more and I just
have less stuff to deal with in my house
and since they halted the fashion
production and we're all using uh we're
supposed to be recusing clothes for the
next hundred years I rent new outfits
with my rent anywhere card from any
store anywhere in the world and it's fun
to see all the people who have owned it
in the last 10 years as well anyway last
night after I watched the wind turbines
I picked up my car which I left charging
one of these supercharged street lights
and I made a few bucks on the way home
swapping out my battery at one of the um
swap stations between here and Marin
honestly this whole decarbonized grid
movement has been great my apartment is
Tiny and like most people now I've got
one table for cooking charging heating
the space in the gas ERA this would have
taken so much more space but now that
we've electrified everything
my life is full of simpler things and
like everyone else my neighborhood is
part of a distributed energy Community
plugged into the city grid but producing
energy all day Guided by software to
help us optimize production with weather
and more and more life has been like
that individuals functioning as an
ecosystem so back to 2023 the world you
just visited is part of an effort we've
been doing to create speculative
conditions for the future with
industrial designers emerging
technologists anthropologists and
certainly we are mostly wrong about the
future but that's not the point
designing our way out of the climate
crisis must consider future scenarios
and friends we are short on Vision the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change has a 40 page PDF of text and
really text is most of what you get if
you search for climate futures
how can we be expected to derive without
the destination in mind
numbers just don't shift Hearts we also
need to be able to collectively picture
shifts down to the minutia down to the
mundane and we need to be able to get
excited about that picture in our minds
this is one of the most widely
circulated non-dystopic visualized
climate Futures and it's from a yogurt
company chopani the fictive community
has brought us some wonderful books and
recently a TV series but we need more we
need more to picture and think about
together so we've been sketching the
human angle of Futures behaviors
products rituals and our goal has been
to create stimula visually Rich enough
to get wheels turning to light a fire
under the organizations that we work
with and ultimately to start our
conversations and we need more
one for each life for your life what
does your life look like in a climate
impacted 2030 no really what just
flashed in your brain
let's get more of those Visions born and
out into the world stay tuned